INTERVIEWER: So I wondered if we
could just go back a little bit
and talk about when you
first started writing recipes
for an audience for the
"Guardian" newspaper,
and when you were asked to
do the vegetarian column,
you weren't a vegetarian chef.
You were known for vegetables.
Maybe tell me a little bit,
what were your thoughts
about having to commit
to the vegetarian lane?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
Well, I speak about it
in the introduction to
the book "Plenty More."
In a sense, I was slightly
petrified for various reasons.
Well, my biggest
fear was that I would
be pigeonholed as
a vegetarian chef.
In the world of cooks and
chefs, at least a few years ago,
cooking vegetables was not
very high on the priority list.
Serious chefs, they cook meat,
and the not so serious chefs,
they cook vegetables.
I'm simplifying it,
but there's a hierarchy
and I didn't want to
be down at the bottom,
or perceived to be
down at the bottom.
The other worry that
I had was that I
was thinking that I've never
written recipes for a living.
I've been cooking
for many years,
but I was worried that I would
run out of suitable ideas
to share with my "Guardian"
readers every week.
I literally thought that I've
got about four, five, six ideas
and then I'm just
going to run out.
I won't have any more
recipes to write.
I think it was a
writer's anxiety.
It's my one and only
I didn't know what
it feels like,
but that's what it
felt like at the time,
so I was slightly
worried about that.
What I write in the introduction
to the book is that in a sense,
I was proven wrong
on both fronts.
For my first concern,
actually, the roles
have almost reversed
in the last few years.
I can't take credit
for this myself,
but I'm probably part
of this change that
has been occurring, that cooking
vegetables, cooking grains
and legumes and lentils and
all those wonderful things
has become much more
appreciated, looked to,
and desirable on all
levels of cooking.
Fancy restaurants,
people at home, everybody
wants to cook more
vegetables and wants
to do marvelous things
with vegetables.
And you can go to the high
end, to the Nomas of this world
and to the Nordic
cuisine, which focuses
very much on foraging
local vegetables.
You can go anywhere
and you'll see
that all of a sudden,
the vegetables
have really moved to the center.
And that's a great
thing, and I think we all
know there's various
reasons for that.
I think the most important
at this point in history
is the fact that eating
vegetables has just
become something that we
can just about imagine
that this world will
be able to support,
and other ways of nurturing
ourselves might not.
With the fear or the anxiety
of running out of ideas,
I think I found myself opening
myself up to the world of food
and all sorts of weird
and wonderful places
through reading, engaging
with people, and traveling.
I have been obsessing about
all sorts of wonderful places
in the world-- Turkey and Iran
and the Far East, Malaysia,
and Vietnam, places that
I feel have something
in common with my Middle Eastern
background, the same kind
of sensibilities when
it comes to food.
I've been celebrating
vegetables ever since.
I put my anxiety to the side.
INTERVIEWER: Has been working
on the vegetarian recipes,
has it changed your palate?
Has it changed the way
you cook and the way
you think about creating a dish?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
I think it has.
First of all, I really
enjoy being limited.
I enjoy the challenge
of being limited,
of creating wonderful
flavors without the help
of a bone or an anchovy,
or all those things
that have intense,
meaty flavor in them
and are really good solutions
for cooking and infusing
flavor.
Many of us, at least,
know how effective
a bone is to make
a stock, or how
fantastical all these
umami flavors are,
but with vegetarian
cooking, you've
got an extra challenge to infuse
things with those flavors.
Hence, I use a lot of
techniques that involve smoking.
When I say smoking,
it's not that kind
of fancy schmancy smoking.
I mean just putting
something on a griddle pan
with a lot of oil, and hence,
you get quite a lot of smoke
around whatever you're
grilling, you're smoking.
Using tons of herbs
and spices and putting
things in conjunction with
other things that really
manage to infuse
them with flavor.
I think what I realized
is with vegetables,
you just need to work
a little bit harder.
INTERVIEWER: You
talked about traveling
a little bit or the different
places you take inspiration
from.
I wonder if there's
a region of the world
or a that you find particularly
inspiring right now,
that you've been thinking
about a lot or looking to?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: With
this book in particular,
I'm very focused on
Persian food, Iranian food.
I think it's a part
of the world that
hasn't been discovered yet.
Well, it has been
discovered by many.
It's not fair what I said.
But it hasn't been exposed
massively to general,
to big audience in the West.
It's the most
wonderful cuisine that
focuses a lot on ingredients
that I just love,
things like saffron,
pomegranates, walnuts.
The Persians, they make
the best rice in the world.
Forget any other rice and
go and cook Persian rice,
because the way they cook it
is based on the rice steaming
with its own residual water
that's left through parboiling,
and the result is
really magnificent.
There are really separate grains
of rice, each one is separate.
And they are absolute
magicians in making
crusty rice, cooking
what is called--
INTERVIEWER: Isn't
there a name for that?
There's a special name.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Tahdig
is the name for that.
And then many Iranian
cooks pride themselves
on the quality of their
tahdig, that crispy thing
that many of us would
treat as an accident,
but for them, it's a
very desirable accident.
It happens every time.
You really want it to happen
because everybody is just
grabbing on to pull that bit of
the rice that's stuck and burnt
a little bit on the
bottom of the pan,
and there's various
ways to enhance that.
INTERVIEWER: In "Plenty," there
was a few ingredients or spices
that you go back to
a lot that I think
are probably new to
lot of American cooks,
like sumac or like
pomegranate molasses.
I'm curious if, in the
new book, were there
some motifs, these things that
you were going back to a lot
and using that might
be new to people?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
There's a bunch
of new ingredients
in "Plenty More" that I've have
been discovering and cooking
with over the last few years.
There's quite a few, but
I will mention a couple.
One of them is black garlic.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with black garlic,
but black garlic
essentially is just
normal garlic that's gone
through a process of aging over
a few weeks under
certain conditions
and at a certain temperature.
It's actually a technique
that's been developed in Korea.
It's new, but it's creates
the most fantastic condiment,
ingredient to use in dressings,
in marinades, and in stews.
Basically, the garlic cloves
turn from white to black,
and they take on
the flavors of what
I can describe as cocoa or
licorice or chocolate or even
coffee and lose all
their garlickiness.
It's a real transformation.
INTERVIEWER: So it's like a
controlled rot, like miso or--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
It's like all those
wonderful things
that we love to eat, like wine,
like all sorts of things that
are absolutely delicious
because of the aging.
So that is one
ingredient that I'm
obsessed with at the moment.
Another ingredient that
I like a lot that's
in one of the recipes
is called kadaifi.
It's a type of Arabic pastry.
Essentially, it's a bit like
shredded wheat in texture
or like angel hair pasta,
but it's filo pastry.
It's very easy to
work with, and it's
got the most unusual texture.
Normally, in Arabic
cuisine, it's
used to make baklavas and
all sorts of desserts,
but I use it in
a savory context.
It's stuffed with cheese
and burned eggplant filling,
and then it turns
into little nests.
And those are put in the
oven, brushed with butter
and served with a Spanish tomato
sauce that I came up with.
The beauty of it is that it's
extremely easy to work with.
You don't need to roll it.
All these people
with pastry angst
should go and try to seek
out this Lebanese or Turkish,
or you can get it from
many shops, pastry.
It's very hard to fail.
You need to be really rotten if
you're going to fail in that.
Everybody can do it.
INTERVIEWER: One
thing you write about
in-- I guess it was
the second book here,
which was "Jerusalem,"
a lot that I thought
was interesting was about
the ownership of dishes,
and how different cultures and
different groups in Jerusalem
and Israel claim
ownership of dishes.
I would say it's interesting,
and I think in the US,
it's maybe a little
foreign to us.
It's not like there's one person
who says, I own the hamburger
or I own fried chicken.
I mean, there are people
who have a lot of pride.
I wonder if you could
talk a little bit more
about that, about
some of that debate
over the ownership of dishes.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It's something
I'm thinking about quite a lot
because at the moment,
I'm trying to understand
a bit about the connection
between food and identity
because lots of my
travels and investigations
lead me towards this
relationship between food
and identity.
I think in what we call
developed countries-- I don't
think "developed" is
the right description,
but it's just a way to
bundle them all together--
the connection between food
and identity, I think somehow
has been severed, or it just
doesn't exist as much as it
used to be, for various
reasons, industrialization.
We all live in cities.
What we cook is
much less related
to what our elders have
cooked for us, et cetera.
I've made a few programs
for Channel Four in the UK,
where I have been traveling
around the Mediterranean
and into all sorts of places,
Tunisia, Morocco, Turkey,
and try to understand the
food through its functions.
And I realized that essentially,
the common denominator
to many of the examples
of what I've seen
is the issue of identity.
When an identity in these parts
of the world is slightly shaky
or is slightly in threat, than
you hang onto what you like
or what you know or what you
think will keep your identity.
Hence what you were talking
about, the sense of ownership.
When the existence is
haphazard and not safe,
you hang onto the things that
are very important to you
and define you.
I think food is extremely
important in Israel
and Palestine because the
reality is very shaky.
So people are very
happy to take ownership,
or are very willing, or
even willing to fight
for the ownership of something
that proves that they have
the right to exist in a certain
way or in a certain place
or over a certain land.
I think that comes.
In writing the book
"Jerusalem," which
was a fascinating experience
and I loved doing it,
but you often come
across this area
where you really need
to tiptoe and make
sure that you don't take
something from one side
by describing it as the
food of the other side,
if you see what I mean.
That is a very crucial thing.
But it happens in other places.
Turkish coffee and Arabic
coffee and Greek coffee
are essentially the
same, but watch out.
If you say Arabic
coffee in Turkey,
they'll chop your head off.
INTERVIEWER: And
related, I love you
talk in "Jerusalem,"
about the hummus debate.
I have to admit, I wasn't aware
that there were sides in this.
Maybe you could
talk about-- I guess
there's the chunky
versus the smooth,
and there's the ratio
of tahini to chickpeas.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Correct, and
how much lemon juice goes in,
and whether there's garlic, and
sometimes people put cumin in.
That is just an extension of
the point that I was making.
In a sense, hummus is the
national dish of both Israelis
and Palestinians, so
very uncomfortable
that warring sides
share a national dish.
It's not a good starting point.
But on the other hand,
it's a very telling thing.
It just shows how close
the sides are in many ways.
So what I call the hummus wars
are a two faceted kind of war.
There is the one
war-- maybe "war"
is a bit of a strong
word in this context,
but I see it a bit like
that-- is about ownership,
and that is when you ask, who
was the first to make hummus?
Of course, the Arabs
around the region,
whether they're Jordanian,
Palestinian, Lebanese, Syrian,
would say us.
I don't think that
is very debatable
that that is the case.
But then the Jews in
Israel tend to say, well,
that's not entirely
true because if you read
in the Old Testament, and there
is this story where something
could actually be interpreted as
hummus, although we're not sure
it's hummus.
And then you know in Judaism,
we can say a million things
and debate them quite
a lot without ever
reaching a conclusion.
There are those
kind of arguments
that claim that hummus
was in the Bible.
But even if it
wasn't in the Bible,
and even if Esau and
Moses didn't eat hummus,
there is one thing
that you can agree on,
is that Jews living in the
Arab world for millennia
have been eating hummus.
And then it's very hard to say
that hummus is Muslim and not
Jewish because the
cultures were interacting.
This is the historical debate.
That's one aspect.
The other aspect is, and that's
much less serious and much more
fun, is who makes
the best hummus?
INTERVIEWER: Right.
Or how do you like it?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Or
how do you like it,
and then that becomes
a matter of a tribe.
You know, I go to
this restaurant,
and I've been going
there all those years,
and he's been making
it in a certain way,
and you're stupid to think
that anyone else could make it
any better.
And then you've
got a lot of these,
I call it skirmishes, little
wars, where two shops or two
restaurants fight on who
makes the best hummus and why.
Again, like you said,
it's a matter of texture,
it's a matter of balance,
it's a matter of this.
And grown-up men can have
serious arguments about hummus.
Normally it's men because
women are more sensible.
Have terrible
arguments about where
is the best place
to have hummus,
and lose friendships
over subjects.
INTERVIEWER: So
what's your answer?
Where is the best place?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
I'm going to have
to sit on the fence on this one.
I mean, there's a
couple of places
in the Old City of Jerusalem
that have been making hummus
in a very traditional way
for many, many generations.
Abu Shukri is one of them.
It's in the Old City, in
the Arab part of Jerusalem,
that makes a good one.
Lina is another one.
They all follow the same
Jerusalem, Palestinian
tradition of hummus, which
is warm-ish, very, very
smooth, and quite
acidic with lemon juice,
or citric acid if
they're cheating.
That's a very particular hummus.
It's a meal.
Most people don't know
that hummus is not
something you eat from a tub.
It's something you eat warm
for your breakfast or lunch
with a pita.
And it's cooked to serve
and then thrown away.
It's not a condiment.
It's not coleslaw.
INTERVIEWER: It's not coleslaw.
Maybe tell me a little
bit, just from reading
the introduction the book.
Your first cookbook, or when
you were doing the "Guardian"
column, you were doing all these
recipes in your kitchen, right?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yes, at home.
INTERVIEWER: And now, you've
been doing this so long
that you actually have an R&D
studio, a test kitchen, a test
lab.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: I've
turned into a mini empire,
a bit like Google.
Yes.
I used to test every
single recipe myself.
Which is kind of fun, but
also a lot of hard work
because I used to go and
shop, and come back and test
the recipe, and clean
up and do the washing,
and then sit and write it.
I could do two recipes a day.
And then with the
years, I started
to have to write more recipes
and publish more books.
So eventually, I took on
a little industrial space
under a railway arch
in central London,
where I have my test
kitchen, and that's
where things are happening.
I figure that it's
actually a much better way
to create recipes
to work in a team.
The whole of "Plenty"
I did on my own.
The whole of "Plenty
More" was done in a team.
I think you get a much
more diverse understanding
of the food and
a better picture.
And sometimes the
discussions or the arguments
about a certain dish lead
into something much better.
Now I'm much more of a
collaborator than I ever was.
INTERVIEWER: Do you prefer
being more of a cookbook author
than actually being in
the kitchen on the line?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yes.
Nowadays, I find
it very relaxing.
I just sit there
and write my ideas
and someone does
all the chopping up,
and then I just need to
come at the right moment
and put it all together.
It's much easier.
But just being a bit
more serious about this,
the joy of actually cooking,
the activity of cooking
is very different from the
activity of making recipes.
When you cook, it's a
visceral, hands-on activity
where you judge things all
the time with your hands,
with your eyes, with your mouth.
When you think up
recipes, it's almost
like an intellectual exercise.
You constantly think.
Sometimes when these
two come together,
they don't do that very well.
They're not best friends.
What seems like a
great idea on paper
just doesn't work in reality.
It's quite important for
me to be on both fronts.
It's not like
architecture, where
you can design a building
that the engineers break
their heads over it.
I need to be there to make
sure that the idea actually
works and comes together.
INTERVIEWER: Now, is that
what led you from-- you
were on a path to academia,
towards getting a PhD.
Did you go into the
kitchen because you
wanted to work with your hands?
Was that it?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
First of all, when
I started to cook,
I felt a sense of liberation,
because I actually
realized that I turned into a
mini slave to my academic life.
I used to come
home and fret over
what I haven't done that day--
haven't read this article,
haven't done this,
haven't done that.
With food, once you're
done, you're done.
Once you've cooked or fed a
group of people or your family
or whatever, it's finished.
It's a very nice feeling
to have that you've
finished your
chores for the day.
I don't know if you know it,
but the feeling that it's
all done and dusted,
that's it, I'm
going home, which is
what happens after you've
done service in a restaurant.
Even though you work
really hard physically,
it's actually a great feeling.
Then you can just not think,
which is a nice thing.
INTERVIEWER: I saw this tweet
that you wrote recently,
and I thought it was very funny.
I'll read it out loud.
It said, "Tofurky vegan
gluten-free pizza makes
me sad."
Can you tell me what
was the context there?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Well,
someone tweeted that picture
of some monstrosity
of a supermarket pizza
that was made out of tofu to
taste like turkey and be vegan.
So essentially, it was so many
wrong things put in one box.
First of all, a pizza
that is not a pizza,
meat that is not meat, and
tofu made to replace dough.
For me, I'm not a purist.
As you probably
know, I play around
with ideas and with recipes,
and I mix a little bit of this
and a little bit
of that, but there
are some things that
are just not done.
And one of them
is try to imitate
one food with the other.
I can't stand veggie burgers.
When you take beans and make
them look as much as possible
as a piece of hamburger or
meat, and I ask myself, why?
Because vegetables
are so fantastic,
why would you want to
turn them into a burger?
I mean, beans are so great.
You take beans and you
put some lemon juice
and garlic and chopped
parsley, maybe cilantro,
and that's the most
delicious thing.
And then you put them
in the food processor
with all sorts of things
that make them look brown,
and then you fry
them on the outside.
That's just for me, it's got all
the wrong things in the world.
I mean, I respect vegetarianism
and I respect veganism
and I respect lots
of things, but I
think there's so many
options without trying
to make one thing taste or
look like something else.
It doesn't work.
INTERVIEWER: I think we'll
open it up to questions,
though my one last
question is, are you
going to open an
Ottolenghi in New York?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: I've answered
this question so many times,
but with the word "New York"
could have been another city.
I'm a terrible
control freak, and I
find it very
difficult to let go.
Hence, I cannot work like other
cooks and open restaurants all
over the world.
We're a close team of
partners that work like that,
and we visit our
restaurants all the time.
It would be very expensive
if I had to come to New York
every time I wanted to
taste my butternut salad.
So I'm afraid it's a no.
INTERVIEWER: It's a no.
All right.
We just have some questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
I think your books have always
been an inspiration for me,
just in terms of
vegetarian cooking.
I was raised vegetarian,
even though I'm
no longer a vegetarian.
My mother is a practicing
Chinese Buddhist.
And part of the culture is
to not eat any living thing,
but as well, on
top of that, things
that are kind of
pungent in nature
so that when you're in
prayer, you're not supposed
to have lingering sense of food.
One challenge that
I have is I have
to cook for her without any
garlic or anything in the onion
family.
So apart from the
things that you've
mentioned, like cumin and other
spices, what other flavoring
ingredients do you
think are a top favorite
that is outside of
those two things?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
You can really take
quite a lot of things
out of your cooking,
because I think there's
so much to substitute.
One of the ingredients that I
use a lot of in such situations
is miso, which is a natural
fermentation of soybeans
or barley or whatever
it is that is
being used in that
particular miso.
It adds a lot of flavor.
And it comes in all
sorts of varieties
with different
types of intensity,
and I think it adds a lot.
I mean, it's never going to
turn into an onion or a garlic.
And you should never try
to turn it into an onion,
hence what I said earlier.
I don't think you
should try this.
But it has a lot of flavor.
I think the idea of not
having onion or garlic
is that it doesn't
linger, so in a sense,
maybe in those
situations, you do
want to make something that
is slightly more bland.
Otherwise, it's kind of cheating
your religion a little bit
if you're going to do something
that is not onion or garlic
but is similar.
I think there's so many things
out there that I would just
choose something that works
without those ingredients.
It's possible.
AUDIENCE: I try to push
her envelope a little bit,
just because there are
vegetarian restaurants
out there, but it's like,
here is a fake beef stir fry.
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: Yeah.
It's all wrong.
If you go to an Asian
[INAUDIBLE] center market where
all this wonderful stuff,
or Middle Eastern mezze,
you can pick a dozen things
that are vegan or vegetarian,
and they've got tons of flavor.
And you don't need to think
about meat or yogurt or all
those things that are
not consumed by some,
and you never feel
that you miss them.
Once you've started
putting into your head
that you have to have something
like something you can't have,
that's where everything
starts to go wrong in my mind.
AUDIENCE: That's great advice.
Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks so much for coming.
You talked a bit at the
start about, I guess,
more developed nations,
as you refer to it,
don't really have to cling onto
the foods from past generations
and appropriate foods from
whatever sources we want.
I guess taking
that to an extreme,
do you see a danger
in maybe what's
happened with hummus,
like you describe?
It just becomes
almost commodified,
and it just becomes very generic
and you can buy it in a store.
Do you see any risk from taking
these very authentic foods,
popularizing them
in your cookbooks,
and are we going to
see McDonald's serving
pomegranate dipping sauce
for their chicken McNuggets
and stuff like that?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: It's
the first I hear of that.
Yes, of course this is the risk.
The smaller the world becomes,
the more we live in cities,
the less you're going to find
ancient traditions preserved
in such a way, and everything
is commodified and turned
into something that is easy to
produce and easy to consume.
I don't think there is
much we can do about it,
but I think you can see the
two opposite trends working
at the same time.
While we want to have hummus on
the shelves in our supermarket,
there's also, at the same
time, a real yearning
for the proper thing,
the real thing.
So you'd find a
little joint somewhere
that people are willing
to queue for hours to get
the authentic experience.
I don't think they
necessarily mean
the extinction of old
ways of doing things.
I'm sure we're going
to see less of them.
They're going to become
more of a curiosity.
There's something about
modernizing, again,
whatever that means,
that means you're
going to see a little bit less
of what is being modernized.
That is a sad fact,
but I don't think
there's that much we could do.
The one thing I
would say, again,
is that one of the
good things that's
come out of this
intense interest in food
that we've seen over the last
20 years on television and just
in people's lives
is that there is,
I think, a real yearning to
things as they used to be
and as they should be.
And hence, people do write
books or open restaurants
or go on pilgrimage
to proper places,
and I think that's
still going to stay.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
INTERVIEWER: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I first
wanted to say that it's
been really great
having your cookbooks.
I'm a vegetarian and
my mom loves to cook.
And it's been a really
big challenge for her
to figure out what
to make for me
and my partner over the years
for holidays like Thanksgiving
and stuff.
So you've presented her with
a really good challenge and me
with some really good
food since they came out.
And I'm also really
excited about the new book.
I have a lot of
Persian Jewish friends
and tend to eat a lot of
Sephardic-type cuisine,
so that will really add to
that experience as well.
My question is a little
bit silly but fun.
I'm going with my parents to
your restaurant in Islington
in December, and is there one
thing, if anything, on the menu
that you would
recommend that we get,
since it's a special experience
because of that bonding?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI:
The trouble is I
don't know what's going to
be on the menu in December
because the menu changes.
So it will be difficult.
But I think you're going to
find the menu is quite small.
It's composed of about 16
dishes, so being vegetarian,
you're going to have to
concentrate on the vegetables.
And there's probably 10
vegetarian dishes on the menu,
and it's sharing,
so you'll probably
just order all of them.
AUDIENCE: I'm down for that.
Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: When
you're in New York,
are there things you
come here, that you
feel like you love that
you get in New York
that you can't find good
versions of in London?
Or is London
cosmopolitan enough now
that you have barbecue
and pizza just like--
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: New York
is by no means-- I mean,
it's got its own sense
of food identity.
There's no Jewish
delis in London,
so there are certain things
you can only get here,
and a few other things.
No, I can't get
everything I want.
INTERVIEWER: Another question.
AUDIENCE: So you were talking
before about ingredients
that people may not be
familiar with that you
expose in your cookbooks.
Personally, I started
cooking with kohlrabi
a lot more after reading your
cookbooks, which I really
enjoy.
But I was wondering,
is there a technique
that you think is really
underused by home cooks
that you think people
should be learning more?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: I'm
really happy you're
asking this question
because I think
what makes "Plenty More" special
in relation to the other books
is the focus on technique.
The book is divided
into chapters
according to cooking
method or cooking
technique-- steamed,
roasted, grilled,
and so on and so forth.
The reason why I decided
to do it this time this way
is because I felt that there
is a lack of understanding
as to how crucial it is
what you do with vegetables.
I think that knowledge
is, to most people,
quite natural when it comes to
meat and when it comes to fish.
Fish you cook very lightly.
You grill them and you
don't mess about with them.
Not many fish are
good for long cooking.
Meat is slightly different.
The prime cuts you eat
seared or almost raw,
and the cheap cuts you
stew, et cetera, et cetera.
So we have that kind
of understanding.
And I give an example
in the introduction
about the fact that if the
steak is not to our liking,
we send it back because we know
what a steak should be like.
And I really don't think the
same applies to vegetables.
I've decided to take the
recipes, which are not
different in a dramatic
way from "Plenty,"
but I decided to divide them
according to the main cooking
technique, because I wanted
to draw attention to the fact
that it really is crucial what
you do with the vegetable.
So I'll take as an example
vegetables that are probably
not a tomato or eggplant,
which are kind of sexy.
I'll take not so sexy vegetables
like a Brussels sprout
or a turnip or a cauliflower
and give you an example.
With a Brussels
sprout, most people
that I know, up until
recently, just threw it
into boiling water and
cooked it and maybe
just added some bacon
later or something.
This book offers tons of ways
to cook Brussels sprouts not
to boil them or over-boil
them, as many people
do-- roasting, grilling,
eating raw in a salad,
deep frying for risotto,
or serving as a salad.
Brussels sprouts are
not loved, I think,
not because they're not good.
It's just because they're
really badly cooked normally.
So I try to take
something like that
and really open it up
completely and have the Brussels
sprout appear in different
chapters in different guises,
and get the readers
and the cooks
to understand how
crucial it is that we
pay the same amount of
respect to the way we cook
our vegetables as we do to meat.
INTERVIEWER: Is there a
vegetable you've tried to like
but just cannot?
YOTAM OTTOLENGHI: No.
I have tried to think of a
vegetable that I don't like,
and I haven't found one yet.
With fruit, it's a
bit more difficult
because there's some
pungent fruits, Asian fruits
like durian, that
are really stinky.
It's very difficult to eat
because it challenges you
on various levels.
But vegetables, no.
I haven't come across
one that I really like.
And kohlrabi that you mentioned
is a wonderful vegetable.
I've just done a
kohlrabi gratin.
By the way, it was inspired
by Deborah Madison, who
is the goddess of
vegetables in my mind.
You'd think that kohlrabi
has a high water content
and the gratin is going to be
watery, but in actual fact,
it's fantastic.
By the time you cook it with
lots of wonderful cheeses,
it's completely moist and it's
got that slight bitterness that
counteracts the
richness of the cheese,
and it's one of the
wonderful things
that everyone should cook.
INTERVIEWER: I want to
leave time for people
to get books signed, so I think
this is probably a good time
to break.
Thanks so much for coming.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]